50 seconds of logos also Comcast
extremely CGI Bertus or well it's not a
Jurassic Park movie if there's not a kid
obsessed with Dinosaurs just once I want
to see how a kid obsessed with Star Trek
fares on an island full of Dino
predators also viewmaster foreshadowing
Judy Greer doesn't have a bigger role in
the sea wholly it's the kid Tony Stark
gave all those gifts do
no wonder he's a daydreamer but let's be
honest at least his home life turned
around am i right I mean he's got his
own room now instead of having to sneak
off to the garage looks like beets
product placement has even infiltrated
the Tony Bennett music videos
apparently the public is warmed to the
idea of a huge dinosaur amusement park
but it's still one you have to take a
flight to Costa Rica and a ferry to
another Island to see with names like
Zack and gray I know for sure I'm not
gonna like these kids Jurassic tennis
Daniel the music for this scene is so
obvious they stole our outtake welcome
to Jurassic world roll credits let's be
honest no one's impressed by a dinosaur
anymore tell that to the viewers that
made this 2015's biggest hit also
Jurassic world steals the same reason
Monsters Inc is in business to justify
the block how did you get two different
kinds of dinosaurs - you know oh
indominus wasn't bred she was designed
blah blah blah no one asked you BD Wong
I'm sure Ron Howard's daughter could
have told him that
but hey glad you could make it to the
Jurassic come back you didn't miss much
between is there somebody who comes back
it covers this stuff in dirt every 10
minutes or so or is this some sort of
exclusive archeological dig but these
kids won't in a contest that first part
was legit movie acknowledges the first
films of Vince's cannon but this new
park was still somehow built you close
the deal looks like it the rise in
Wireless presents the indominus rex
movie truck full of product placements
makes fun of brand deals so that
Hollywood will see more like people
you're not even looking at her dude and
that it tried to break the glass but
only the one time and never again sits
because while it's a smart dinosaur it's
actually quite stupid you see we've been
taught that Raptors are so insanely
smart they can figure out puzzles and
attack and patterns but apparently with
enough gung-ho attitude you can train
them to be your bitches I just saw a
bond a real bond
it's just in Chris Pratt is the new bomb
we know that the military needs to
reduce casualties introducing probably
the worst part of this movie the already
super villain company hoping to recruit
these animals for war purposes but what
do they need these dinosaurs for when
they have the t-virus or am i confusing
my movies again also only fill military
is using Raptors to fight wars don't
other militaries just decide to bomb the
living out of such a fighting force you
don't send dudes on the ground to fight
Raptors right drones can't search
tunnels and caves and their hackable the
minute a real war breaks out all that
fancy tech is gonna go dark so better
bank on velociraptors makes perfect
sense let's see things are getting
boring and we need an action scene let's
have this guy be an F that is job also
is a loose pig really that urgent a
problem what the pigs only here to
service food for the dinosaurs anyway
okay
I'm pretty sure there's a 95% chance he
would be eaten here but with the evil
military guy in here these Raptors are
going to do everything in their power to
move that plop forward and they try and
eat him as soon as he moves for the
safety of the gate but later they'll be
running alongside his motorcycle not
chomping on his delicious face don't
ever turn your back to the cage which is
what I'm gonna do right now I know this
is Costa Rica where laws may be more
lacks but this is just an insurance
fucking nightmare this Park again how
did it ever get built even out of the
u.s. they're gonna be sued 2500 times a
year at a minimum they cover up the dork
pouch interestingly this is also how
kangaroos mock their dirty siblings this
place sells Dino balloons with almost no
helium in them so they appeared to be
walking on the ground which means they
lose what little helium they have very
quickly and are just an overpriced brief
waste of time at least if you buy the
pterodactyl balloon it comes with full
helium out of the box am I supposed to
laugh or wince at this Jurassic world
the theme park feels half parody of the
over commercialization of Disney and
other theme parks and half actually what
would happen in this movies reality
expects me to believe that only this one
child is running for the t-rex exhibit
after that announcement
do you even kid screenwriter Wow a cell
phone reception is excellent on a remote
Costa Rican island I went to Montana
last summer and found how t-mobile
doesn't have any service in that state
like at all but the Costa Rican ocean
King blanketed in cell coverage this was
supposed to be a family weekend Claire
skipped there's apparently no such thing
as calling a guy on the phone when it
comes to asking for his help nope we
need a full scene of chris pratt
exerting his male dominance over the
alpha female also I wonder how much
Jurassic world paper Sadie's to slide
this movie into their car commercial
made what Owens nickname must be Daniel
son did this movie just have its jock he
wrote it to fly in midair Jesus I don't
control the Raptors it's a relationship
it's bull whatever label you want to put
on it dude that's right you and I never
had a second date why is it every time
there's a woman who needs to find some
man for a job in movies they've dated
before you might want to change your
shirt they're very sensitive to smell
way to get back at him for all that
sexist dialogue - it's I mean this is
the 30s right I can get away with
calling her that only the first Rover -
God slickers
even though roughly 32 rows were
drenched by the Moses or spirit
pre-booking tickets for months okay what
you waited until now to seek an expert's
opinion on the pack and also this is the
first anyone's hearing about it on the
island even though it's been public
knowledge on the mainland for three
months the base genome is a t-rex the
rest is classified you might as well say
Raptor then or lie also how can you ask
a dude to evaluate the prospective
worthiness of a Dino paddock without
telling him what he's dealing with I
know we're supposed to understand that
engine hires these lacks lazy security
guards because they don't give a but
come on it's just piling on with
siblings they learned social skills and
I am print on them when they're born and
now I'm picturing that creepy Twilight
baby thank you
also we just heard that the indominus
was born with a sibling she ate it
so all this smart talk by Owen to make
him look like the world's foremost
authority on Dino psychology and shame
the company for their misdeeds comes off
just a little Hollow when we know that
plus she never tells Owen this for some
reason Claire gets in the car and call
HQ about tracking the indominus instead
of doing that before we're leaving the
paddock remember this thing could be
anywhere including the parking lot also
we can show how deaf this new dinosaur
is and so she can't relay the
information in time to Owen who stupidly
goes inside the cage when you think
about it this is just the indominus his
protest against Jurassic Park 3 Radio
crafts out right when they need it to
work and despite the excellent cell
phone coverage demonstrated earlier like
all doors in these movies they close
with the speed of a vic-20 computer
meanwhile you have a SeaWorld attraction
at your park where you can lower a whole
stadium of people in way less time
plenty at the street the guy who got out
of the paddock first decided I'll hide
in front of my truck instead of you know
getting in the truck and driving away
that's what you get for eating
sandwiches on the job it's amazing
engine thought this dinosaur would be
their business Savior when it's
basically just t-rex to the Rex inning
my watch came at me with a steak knife
took a chunk in her do you get the sense
Vincent D'Onofrio invented this
backstory about raising a wolf pup
strictly first character amazing the guy
who wants to use Raptors for war has
this convenient history affair yep this
also looks like a serious death risk for
the park visitors but control systems
are in place to keep this herd from
knocking over the truck of course or one
of us be with mommy annoyed dad gives it
in fact who gives it about these kids at
least Lexington were part of the action
from the get-go
these kids were dropped off by a Z rated
babysitter and they offer nothing
absolutely nothing to this movie
which happens Dan's leave no need to be
a pussy about it look
they're gonna get to everything right
you're gonna get two birthdays two
Thanksgivings to accept parents right
how do you not shut down all attractions
an issue an evacuation order with a
genetically enhanced hybrid t-rex on the
loose
I made a sea of bears that the elevator
even allow him on this floor you know
you can make elevators do amazing things
these days right including keeping out
unauthorized personnel she marked up
that wall as a distraction she wanted us
to think she escaped and she knew that
you had cameras that detected thermal
signatures and somehow knew she needed
to reduce her body temperature so she
couldn't be detected I know when I was
born I already had the theory of
calculus down pat so that's legit I'm
going after her with non-lethal we have
26 million dollars invested in that
asset who he steals the polarizer from
aliens that's her tracking implant she
plotted out how would it know to do that
she remembered where they put it in and
she knew exactly what it was apparently
they're putting something in my body
must be a way to track me it's kind of
cool actually
but this is the last time this really
smart dinosaur does anything cool the
rest of the movie all it becomes after
this is a remorseless eating machine
evacuate the island we'd never reopen oh
okay then keep it open
dinosaur nerd kid cliche bumps up
against older brother who's only
interested in girls cliche and I'm
honestly actively rooting for both these
dickheads to die so they're if their
genetic code was pure many of them would
look quite different but take that
people who nitpick Jurassic Park on the
look of the dinosaurs shame on you and
the Pickers shame Jimmy felt no we can
stay out a couple more minutes
dinosaur amusement park allows rides
that can be personally controlled by
teenagers they made these where there's
no communication available other than
your own cell phones it's almost like
engine was writing a screenplay when
they made these things now I'm just
worried that you're not getting the full
Jurassic world experience amazing on the
day that Claire's nephews came to the
park that's when all that went down and
they're assholes too which makes it even
more fun there's five dinosaurs aren't
you supposed to be a genius or something
yeah genius if you see five dinosaurs
including one that looks like the t-rex
got dipped in x-men mutagen why are you
being so goddamn vague and calm about it
also indominus rex his path manages to
go exactly where the people were
supposed to care about go the phone call
intended to help save the kids actually
puts the kids in further danger this
happened in the last movie
when he thinks that I will experience
satisfactory thrills if it literally
repeats the first movies kids in peril
scene but with a change from night to
day and two boys instead of a
brother-sister indominus managed to miss
two kids with what is basically a huge
jacket piece of glass at this point
thank God dinosaurs hate water the baby
Donnell from American sniper thinks this
looks fake as it didn't eat him it's
killing for sport and that my friends is
how a dinosaur gets more character than
all the humans in this movie would love
a situation here is this guy really been
tracking hoskins movements this whole
time when he's not training Raptors is
he this Islands official Coast Guard or
something know anything about dinosaurs
stay here stay here stay here Jurassic
world is so concerned it's not paying
enough respect at Jurassic Park it puts
in a whole scene paying respect to
Jurassic Park you only fixed up
grandpa's old Malibu right ah sudden car
savviness even before the Dino breakout
this park is clearly over capacity that
thing is a killing machine he's talking
about indominus rex but he could just as
easily be talking about Hoskins diet
they'll take this stronger than me just
goes to show guys if you've been an
asshole to your brother all your life
all it takes is an indominus rex attack
to set yourself straight once again the
indominus finds its way around the main
characters but all we've been hearing
about is how it's making a beeline south
towards the park this is not too far
from where we lost our when she was
attacking those two kids before they ran
here
so I guess despite the fact she's
currently moving south she's doing it in
a zigzaggy east-west motion dinosaur we
know has knowledge of thermal radiation
and tracking devices didn't bother
taking Owens gun on the way out yeah I
remember that scene well I mean we have
to acknowledge that the indominus isn't
that big a target so even the best of us
could miss something like this hey I
have an idea about how we can get to the
silly plot line with Hoskins and the war
Raptors let's have the owner of engine
fly us helicopter make absolutely no
impact on the plot crash and die okay
safe now why would you say this tear
Demick movie leaves behind the two
brothers for a bit so we can experience
true horror and seen her future
nightmares by traveling along with this
chick as she gets repeatedly captured
tortured and eaten by flying dinosaurs
also a lot of you love the scene and I
don't know if I blame you but for the
very fact that Zara never once was a
character in this movie merely playing
an occasional cutaway shot the impact
this scene could have had is lost
because she's really not much above an
extra in this movie
something sharp crashes towards
characters and comes to a complete stop
at the last second cliche this is a good
time to do that he has this insane plan
to use the laughter you mean the giant
genetically enhanced dinosaur we haven't
seen or heard from in almost 20 minutes
of screen time I know Hoskins is insane
so maybe sending the fact that he thinks
this is going to work is ridiculous in
itself but the guy saw Owen control the
raptors one time from an elevated
position and suddenly that equals now we
can use the raptors to fight indominus I
think even insane people would need more
data this is happening with or without
you so the release of the raptors into
the open is happening with or without
the only guy who can somewhat control
them the statement might be the dumbest
thing in this entire movie empty threat
is empty Owen has all the power here do
that ghost at the old house you mean the
one that made him go into the further
probably not also movie hints at a much
better movie we will sadly never see
luckily the indominus somehow knowing
she had a tracking device lodged in its
skin and tearing it out becomes a
convenient way for the raptors to
ironically track her the old-fashioned
way also at what point did they get this
patch of skin with the tracker back
remember when the soldiers found it this
guy was holding it got thrown to the
water and stopped so I guess they sent
people on a mission to go recover that
piece of flesh and the only way they
could find it the tracker remained
miraculously intact so the big final
plan is for the raptors to lead the way
to indominus followed by owen on a
motorcycle french dude on a four-wheeler
and the kids and girl they're trying to
protect in the van that follows these
raptors somehow race toward this
indominus as though they thought the
four of them could defeat it but now
that they're facing it they're like oh
dude but we think it they communicating
yeah but doesn't the indominus have zero
social skills wasn't that the reason it
became a murdering psychopath so the
raptors just instantly fall in line with
this thing because it's big and it
speaks raptor movie turns into Tarak
evolution what is your way call it a
chopper I'm not sure why I only thought
of this now but just do it
we'd like to thank you for your patience
while many of you were being killed
someone has to stay behind they do what
have you done to this point that
requires your presence sure you get your
big moment later when you open the t-rex
paddock that's about it
nature is to kick well I'm glad to see
him get his comeuppance especially at
the hands of a raptor but deep blue sea
called and they'd like their character
suddenly killed during a big speech back
also random Raptor shows up on the scene
apparently knowing the layout of the lab
to run straight to this room interrupts
Hoskins mid monologue knows who the bad
guy this movie is and goes straight for
now they're blocked on both sides by
Raptors when the end looks near which
means the heretofore unseen t-rex is
going to save the day because we're
paralleling the first movie hard here
people goddamnit
a minute ago you guys said goin I love
the indominus now now that only takes
your harnesses off you suddenly switch
sides for no real apparent reason other
than Raptor style junk
why did you specifically radio for Lowry
did you know that the slacker game is
going to be the one person to stay
behind
is this a Marvel movie now we once again
going to see something fight at slightly
bigger twin um she cannot outrun a t-rex
remember the first movie when they're in
the Jeep must go faster Jeff Goldblum's
torso I thought y'all were kidding about
the heels but goddamn
what you mean you're not gonna try and
get her on your side thankfully the
t-rex they released is more interested
in killing genetically enhanced
dinosaurs than it is in killing humans
this thing come from I thought all the
Raptors were dead Raptor X market I
guess everywhere these assholes roam the
fight follows them this is an awesome
head Nick but how did the underwater
thing know that the indominus thing was
right here at this moment doing
indominus things t rex raptor diplomacy
why do we just assume that because the
indominus is dead all the danger is over
now there are loose animals all over the
park but i guess after the t-rex and the
raptor had their heart-to-heart all the
wild dinosaurs just no-win enough set up
we promise not to get divorced now ever
since cinemasins began the most
requested thing has been TV since and
now it's a reality click the link in the
description below to check it out and
now the audio outtakes
Apollo 13 flight controllers listen up
what the hell
it's in the cage the call is coming from
inside the house
[Music]
the chants are gonna have the Dayton ah
the Jets are gonna have their ways we're
going to brawl together and we're gonna
find a way to get out first
we call yeah we're cool